today the Matt wall show Public Health
experts encourage gay men to continue
having orgies and attending fetish
festivals in spite of monkey pox what
exactly explains the incredible contrast
between the monkey pox response and the
covet response I have a few theories
that I'll share also reptilian demon
spawn George Soros pledges to continue
funding and facilitating the violent
chaos in our cities also more victims of
alleged Sesame Street racism step
forward and demand cash of course Gordon
Ramsay faces backlash as a tick talkers
discovered with horror where their food
comes from and our daily cancellation
even Beyonce is not safe from the woke
mob now all of that and more today on
the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
you know you've heard me talk a lot on
this show about how important it is to
get your kids away from the garbage that
they're teaching in our Public School
Systems Marxism socialism critical race
Theory the transgender all of it now
there are a lot of ways you can protect
your kids from these not so secret
leftist attacks you can homeschool you
can get them involved in a religious
community you can get them the right
books to read like my best-selling
children's book Johnny The Walrus by the
way these things are all great and you
should do them but what if you couldn't
no one likes to talk about it but we
will all eventually die
quite a transition that's just how life
works the end result is always the same
some of us however however may die
sooner than others and we need to be
prepared for that possibility because if
we're not prepared if we if we haven't
taken the necessary steps to Shield our
kids from the aggressive attacks and
indoctrination attempts coming from the
left then we've left them completely
unarmed and unprotected that's why you
should take five minutes to sit down
tonight and write a will that will
ensure your kids will be raised the way
you would have intended in the event
that something should happen to you
lucky for you my sponsor over at Epic
will makes it really easy to do that
epic will it's an online platform that
costs less than your next trip to the
store they can set you up with a will in
as little as five minutes starting at
just 119 plus you can save 10 when you
go to epicwail.com and use code Walsh go
to epicworld.com use my code Walsh today
following in the footsteps of New York
and Illinois California has officially
declared a state of emergency because of
the monkey pox outbreak Governor Newsom
announced the move on Monday explaining
that the state of emergency would help
facilitate the state's vaccination drive
as of now he says there is far more
demand for the amongst monkey pox
vaccine and there is Supply
meanwhile and this happened just this
morning President Biden is still of
course battling through his 19th bout
with covid but he still announced his
newly assembled monkey pox Response Team
think of them as sort of like the
Avengers except for blisters Robert
Fenton of FEMA is now the national
monkey pox coordinator and Dr Dimitri
deskalakis of the CDC will be his Deputy
his Robin to his Batman I suppose I know
I'm mixing DC and Marvel forget about it
it's um it's a good thing though that we
have both FEMA and the CDC on the case
because both organizations are renowned
for making every problem worse and I
think they're vast experience with being
totally incompetent and useless will be
very important in this case especially
after all making the problem worse
Fanning the Flames dumping fuel on the
fire would seem to be the overall sort
of agreed upon strategy with respect to
Monkey pox
for example in San Francisco a day
before the virus was declared a
Statewide emergency with you know the
lines for the vaccines still stretching
around the corner an annual gay fetish
Festival was still held as scheduled
um your grandfather died alone in a
nursing home because you weren't allowed
to visit him due to covid and your kids
were locked out of school for a year but
gays in San Francisco were still having
their sex Festival even amid an outbreak
that specifically spreads through those
sorts of events in that community
uh local news Outlet reports quote the
annual door alley Festival happened
Sunday in San Francisco Soma
neighborhood despite growing concerns
about the spread of monkey pox the virus
has been predominantly spreading among
gay and bisexual men who make up the
majority of the festival's attendees the
leather and fetish Fair draws thousands
of people to San Francisco the event
comes after the city just declared a
public health emergency for monkeypox of
the as the virus continues to spread
I think the via the risk is not zero you
CSF infectious disease specialist Dr
Peter chin Hong said I think if people
are smart and know how monkey products
is spread they can avoid it chin Hong
says that the risk of Contracting the
virus at events like door alley is very
low
however that risk increases based on
intimate interactions with others quote
prolonged skin-to-skin contact and
possibly through sexual transmission
although skin to skin contact is the
main thing chin Hong added so that's
large in terms of medium that will be
prolonged kissing through saliva but it
requires hours hugging by itself giving
a high five shaking somebody's hand is
not going to result in transmission he
says
oh well that's a relief you know if
you're attending the gay fetish Carnival
to give high fives and um Shake people's
hands then you should be fine he assures
us
anyway the good news is that the event
was also an educational opportunity the
report continues uh quote event
organizers say they're working with the
city's Public Health Department to
provide on-site Outreach and education
despite precautions chin Hong expects to
see more cases after this weekend quote
I expect a lot of activity next week in
terms of alerts chin Hong says
so to review this public health expert
and infectious disease specialist says
that the risk of Contracting monkeypox
at a fetish Festival in a city that's a
monkey pox hot spot is very low
and yet he anticipates purely by
coincidence more virus um activity
directly after the event concludes
now the San Francisco AIDS Foundation
which is a non-profit which has worked
closely with the city's Public Health
Department for decades they issued their
own sort of guide
for this Festival which which they are
calling douchey's guide to door
with quote some ideas to reduce your
risk and still enjoy your favorite Kink
and fetish festival in San Francisco
the guide begins quote we're gearing up
for an exciting return of our favorite
Street Festival in San Francisco up your
alley AKA door alley where you'll get
your fill of hot hairy Daddy's Hungry
Pigs BDSM babes and Kinks of all kinds
douchey's got some hot tips for a fun
and filthy weekend free of anxiety
we are then given a variety of tips and
some of them I can't even read out loud
to you and really I should read any of
them out loud but here's one tip she it
says um take a friend to the dungeon
going to sex parties with people you
know and planning on who you'll hook up
with can be one way to reduce your risk
if you're able to have open and honest
conversations about monkey pox symptoms
and possible exposures
so make sure to have open and honest
conversations in The Sex Dungeon they're
saying the guide also cautions that you
should perhaps you know think about
avoiding the piles of gay men having sex
with each other in dark back rooms and
instead stick to having orgies in
well-lit areas also if you appear to be
breaking out in Monkey pox rashes
yourself
well then of course the guide says stay
home don't go
just kidding the AIDS Foundation
recommends that you just cover your
bumps with a Band-Aid and head out onto
the town anyway that's really what it
says
you could actively be breaking out in
Monkey pox uh just you know wear long
sleeves put some Band-Aids on go have go
have fun in the orgy
this is a sort of Health advice
that's being dispensed for monkey pox
any warnings or suggestions or policies
more stringent than this would be
shaming to the gay community we can't
have that
that's what California legislator Scott
weiner whose name will never stop being
funny recently explained on Twitter he
tweeted quote lots of sex shaming of gay
men around monkeypox the same shaming we
saw in 1980s about HIV lecturing people
not to have sex isn't a public health
strategy it didn't stop HIV it made it
worse and it won't stop monkey pox what
will work is vaccination testing and
education
well what about educating people about
the fact that fetish festivals and
orgies are disgusting and barbaric and
are guaranteed to be vectors of all
kinds of diseases
can we educate people about that no we
can't impart that sort of Education
because it's simply not a good Public
Health strategy to tell gay men to make
good health decisions and to encourage
them to please refrain from recklessly
spreading their bodily fluids all over
town yet it was a good Public Health
strategy to shut down all of society for
a year or more that was perfectly
reasonable practical
to tell people to stay in their homes
and not go anywhere or do anything for
months on end that's reasonable
practical but telling gay men just hey
refrain from the orgies for a couple of
weeks
in fact I made this point in response to
Weiner and some guy named Lane wood who
has a blue check so again we know he's
important responded tagging Twitter and
Twitter CEO he said to me hey Twitter
safety I know these are not easy calls
to make and technically Matt Walsh's
tweets don't cross lines yet I don't
care that he has the views he does he's
allowed however
we know this is Paving the path to
violence for his audience
so I didn't say anything wrong or
incorrect whether factually or morally
and I didn't violate any Twitter
policies but Lane wants me banned anyway
because somehow the simple truths I'm
discussing might pave the path to
violence
this is of course a common view on the
gay lift on Friday a gay news site lgbtq
Nation published an article with the
headline monkeypox is not a gay disease
but it is being painted that way
worldwide touting the monkey pox virus
as a gay disease endangers both queer
and non-queer people
now to be perfectly clear about this I
don't think
that monkey pox is a gay virus
I doubt it has any particular sexual
orientation at all though I haven't
asked I also don't know its pronouns I
wouldn't presume to assume what I do
know is that it's a disease which
infects gay men nearly exclusively
nearly in part helped by the fact that
gay men are nearly exclusively nearly
the the ones attending fetish festivals
and orgies that's what I do
two other important points I think
should be made here
first you you notice how often
LGBT people are endangered by the truth
according to the left
you know they they spread this ring of
eggshells around LGBT people and demand
that we walk gingerly on them all the
time
there are a million fantasies false
Impressions delusions that we're
supposed to keep intact a million
bubbles we must not burst
this is how the left wants us to see it
anyway
but this approach not only places a
ridiculous unfair burden on all of us
who are forbidden from speaking the
basic truth commanded constantly to lie
but it also harms the very people it's
supposed to protect the truth
that we must Shield LGBT people from are
um these these truths are always and in
every case exactly the truths that they
most need to hear
so who who is the compassionate one the
loving one
is it the guy who shouts to the person
about to walk right off a cliff
attempting to warn him about the plunge
ahead
or is it the guy who tries to muffle the
other guy preventing him from issuing
the warning
which one is loving and compassion
second Point
um there are several reasons why gay
people are allowed rather encouraged
actually to continue running around town
having sex with strangers during
monkeypox while the rest of us were made
to put our entire lives on hold during
covet the most obvious reason is that
gays are a protected privilege class and
therefore they have different rules
um and they just they live by different
set of rules than the rest of us do
but there's something else too and and
it's this
the left believes
that no right is as sacred as the right
to sexual gratification
okay in fact by their doctrines there
really is no right other than the right
to sexual gratification that is that's
that is every right boils down to this
one
the right to be sexually satisfied every
Liberty is grounded in this
according to them we have no right to do
anything except satisfy ourselves
sexually
this is by their view in their dreary
miserable vision of the world
um this is what it is there is no
meaning to life other than the pursuit
of temporary carnal pleasure
this is why they can't bear to abstain
or tell others to abstain even them in a
monkey pox outbreak
a life without immediate constant sexual
satisfaction satisfaction is a life
without meaning
a life without purpose
it is a kind of death
to tell people to control themselves
sexually for even a day
is to
essentially kill them
that's the way the left looks at it
because this right trumps everything
the right to be sexually satisfied
certainly trumps any concern for safety
or health
especially the safety and health of
other people who themselves have no
worth except so far as they could be
used sexually and discarded
this is what lies at the heart of the
public health approach to Monkey pox and
also of course at the heart
of every other insane thing in our
culture
now let's get to our five headlines
foreign
[Music]
back to school season is uh upon us and
while many American kids are excited to
get back into the classroom many others
are not because these children don't
know where their meals will be coming
from this semester that's why good
ranchers has made it their mission to
donate a hundred thousand high quality
meals to kids facing food insecurity and
malnourishment this fall semester for
every box order through the month of
August good ranchers will donate a
nutritious meal to a child in need help
them Reach their goal of a hundred
thousand donated Meals by ordering your
box today at goodranchers.com Walsh good
Rancher is an award-winning food
delivery service that ships 100 American
Meat and also a seafood right to your
door name the best food Subscription
Service earlier this year good ranchers
is the fastest growing Meat Company in
America they Source only the best
American Farms so you can trust that
you're feeding your family with the
highest possible quality every single
day plus right now you can use my code
Walsh to get 30 off your order plus free
shipping your purchase furthers their
mission to donate a hundred thousand
high quality meals to children need is a
great cause that we should all rally
behind so go to goodranchors.com Walsh
today use my code Walsh when you place
your order and let's help these guys hit
their goal
all right before we continue I wanted to
tell you about a little bit of personal
news actually not a little bit it's a
big personal news so one night in early
June
um this this past June my wife walked
into the living room and she was holding
a little pink stick and it was kind of
the familiar
set up to a scene that's played out a
few times in our marriage and uh you
know she of course told me that she was
pregnant now it might seem strange when
I tell you that her pregnancy came as a
shock to both of us because we are a
married couple with four kids already
you would think that by now we've kind
of
figured out how these things work but in
fact 10 years ago before our Twins were
born we were told that it was unlikely
we'd ever have children at all that's
what the doctors told us and then we had
the Twins and with each pregnancy we
were kind of told the same thing well
this is probably the last one and then
we had our uh our youngest daughter
almost three years ago and we were told
the same thing we we started to believe
it almost three years go by and
um we kind of settled into this idea
that okay we're gonna have four kids we
just in fact bought a car that fits our
family of six perfectly like the day
before this news came down and
um you know God had other plans as is so
often the case
so a couple weeks later my wife went for
an ultrasound and I stayed with the kids
and she came out of the appointment
with a mysterious look
on her face and she handed me the
ultrasound picture and I looked at it
and uh sure enough you know as expected
there was the little circle which is our
our baby
and right next to that one another
little circle because there's another
baby
and we're having twins again we're
having another set of twins almost a
decade almost exactly a decade after the
first set now we're gonna give it
another go
I'm gonna be totally honest with you
there was a you know the reaction it's
it's there's a lot of
we've been like I said we've been
through this before but
a lot of emotions come rushing it a
little bit of panic said in it first I
will admit that I may have
for a moment sort of doubled over and
looked like someone catching his breath
after a five mile run this was just not
on my radar at all to use an online
cliche that I hate this wasn't on my
bingo card let's just say
but you know life would be very boring
if
you always got what you expected or what
you planned for
the excitement in life and the joy of it
it comes from embracing the unexpected
adjusting your swing for the for the
curveballs I guess there's also the
Hallmark of true adulthood
so my wife and I uh I you know I'm not
gonna say we're ready because we learned
from the first set of twins you can
never actually be ready to have twins
but we we are ready to do what we aren't
ready for if that makes sense
and we're grateful and we're excited and
frankly a little bit terrified but all
of that is part of part of life that's
all that's all that's all the joy of
life and the other good thing
is that my wife and I
are single-handedly staving off the
population decline we are we we've got
this we're taking control
we will get us all above replacement
level we'll do it
and I am also taking over the world with
my progeny so one step closer
to my vision of a Theocratic fascist
dictatorship
if I can't you know if I can't
get to that position through votes then
I'll just I'll uh I'll get there through
sheer numbers
all right
um there's no stopping us now I guess
all right so let me uh let me go here
first here's something heartwarming it's
a news report
out of Los Angeles about an attempted
armed robbery of a convenience store and
I will play this Clifford this is the
the local news report let's go ahead and
play this
strategically tucked behind the counter
cope whipped out his hidden shotgun and
blasted the suspect in the arm as the
man took off another camera captured
this
the suspects after nearly leaving one of
their own behind sped off in a black BMW
X3
now you notice how these people they uh
first of all they almost always run when
they encounter resistance and I just
love everything about that start
shouting and screaming there it looks
like there are three of them there
and they're all armed
and they get they get resistance and
they start running away they try to
ditch the one guy and he manages to jump
in but hopefully they've backed into the
parking spot and they're showing their
uh their license plate right to the
security camera so that was very helpful
and nice of them
but this is what you you know when you
see these great videos of the would-be
victims refusing to be victims
you you almost always see this where the
the uh the predator
right who has now become the prey just
collapses and runs away immediately and
why does that happen it's because
they're they're cowards
um it's also because they're not
expecting resistance of any kind they're
not they're not expecting any sort of
accountability at all
and that's thanks in large part to
what's happening in these cities
especially with the Marxist DA's who
refuse to prosecute and punish criminals
many of those DA's installed with the
help of George Soros who uh just this
week wrote a defiant op-ed in the Wall
Street Journal doubling down and saying
that he's not going to stop funding
these DA's no matter how much violence
and chaos and death and destruction and
misery and suffering is caused by all
this he's not going to stop you know
he's going to keep doing it because
those things are those are not bugs
those are features I mean that's the
point anyways of course he's going to
continue
I'm going to read a little bit from this
op-ed from George Soros he says
Americans desperately need a more
thoughtful discussion about our response
to Crime people have had enough of the
demagoguery and divisive partisan
attacks that dominate the debate and
obscure the issues like most of us I'm
concerned about crime one of
government's most important roles is to
ensure Public Safety I've been involved
in efforts to reform the criminal
justice system for more than 30 years
but for the more than 30 years I have
been a philanthropist
that's one way of putting
putting it yet our system is Rife with
injustices that make us all less safe
the idea that we need to choose between
Justice and safety is false they
reinforce each other if people trust the
justice system it will work and if the
justice system works Public Safety will
improve we need to acknowledge that
black people in the U.S are five times
as likely to be sent to jail as white
people that is an injustice that
undermines our democracy we spent 81
billion dollars every year keeping
around 2 million people in prisons and
jails we need to invest more in
preventing crime with strategies that
work deploying mental health
professionals and crisis situations
investing in youth job programs and
creating opportunities for uh education
Behind Bars that's what we really needed
and that's seen there where the armed
robbers come in
what what he should have done what the
guy should have done rather than
shooting them he should have uh got on
the horn right away with some mental
health professionals
and maybe some you know uh maybe some
representatives of a job programs who
can show up and say well the only reason
you guys are doing this because you
don't have you can't get a job right
what was it that AOC said you're hungry
for bread
then we have some Bakers show up with a
loaf of bread here you go
a couple of points about this first of
all
it's only an injustice
that black people are more likely to be
sent to jail if
black people aren't more likely to
commit crimes that would put them in
jail so we hear this all the time
that black people are whatever the
number is four or five times more likely
to go to jail
and this is just presented without any
other context as clear evidence of
racial Injustice but don't we need a
little bit more information
now if black people and white people
statistically as a group were equally as
likely to commit violent crimes and were
responsible for an equal proportion of
violent crimes and yet you discovered
that one group was incarcerated far more
often than the other then absolutely I
would be the first to say this is
evidence that there's something uh
horribly wrong here and it's probably
evidence of racial Injustice
but that's not what you find when you
look at the numbers
the crime rate between white and black
people
would have to be the same in order for
the incarceration rate to be unjust but
the crime rate is not the same
it's just simply not
and that's all
and that you know we can take this logic
and extend it to the two million people
who are in jail right now white or black
because that's the other thing we're
always told as George Soros does here so
we got two million people in jail
clearly that's that's too many we
shouldn't have that many people
of course you know you notice they never
tell us how many people they think
should be in jail in a in a country of
300 and whatever 50 million you're going
on 350 million uh people how many should
be in jail in your mind what like a
thousand ten what do you what do you
think is a reasonable number
what what number are you going to pull
arbitrarily out of your hat
but you've decided that 2 million is too
many
well but that's only in an example
that's only a symptom of over
incarceration
if we are incarcerating people who are
not dangerous criminals
so if Society is generally peaceful and
safe but there's a bunch of people in
prison then maybe you might look at that
and say well you know what's going on do
all these people really need to be in
prison
but given that our societies are
descending our society and our cities
are descending ever further into
violence and Anarchy
the problem is clearly under
incarceration not over incarceration
that is quite obviously the problem
because all you have to do is walk into
any City and you're going to find that
the streets are crawling with violent
criminals who should be in jail and are
not so that is an under incarceration
problem
we've got two million people in jail
um
that is a shocking number because it
should be way higher than that
I don't know what the number should be
okay I'm not going to come up with
arbitrary numbers but certainly way
higher
and my evidence
is all the people in all these
communities Across America that are
committing violent crimes and are not in
prison
this is not what you know
what you hear from the other side on
this the the side that calls for
Criminal Justice Reform
which is another euphemism I mean I I
support Criminal Justice Reform too I
just think that it should be reformed
the other way
you know it should be reformed in the
direction of actually
finding detaining punishing and
segregating from society dangerous
criminals that's what I that's the kind
of Reform I would like to see
for the people who support so-called
Criminal Justice Reform and it's in you
know uh in its current state
this is not compassion
okay this is not concerned for their
fellow man this is nihilism this is
disregard for human life
you know George Soros is 6 000 years old
a billionaire living you know he's I
think he's technically an American
citizen
um I don't know how much time he
actually spends in this country
but he's not living in these he's
certainly not he's certainly not
spending any time in these communities
where these sorts of things are
happening
he's not going anywhere near like a a
convenience store in in uh the bad parts
of Los Angeles which you know the whole
part is all of Los Angeles is the bad
part now but he's not going anywhere
near these a convenience store that
might get robbed by three armed men
so it's really easy for him to sit back
it's the same for you know all the
elected Democrats and
almost everyone on the left who calls
for this they're not in these
communities where these things are
happening
and they're totally morally dead inside
because when you see all these crimes
and and so often now they're caught on
video in fact I just saw right before I
went on the air there's security camera
footage of uh some some kids in what
appears to be basically a Suburban
neighborhood at a lemonade stand
were robbed at gunpoint at a lemonade
stand
now
again that's that's a symptom of the
under incarceration problem
but when you see that
you should be filled with rage
righteous rage and anger
at the Predators who are victimizing
these people
that's the feeling you should have
if you immediately sympathize with The
Predator then there's something wrong
with you deeply
and certainly with George Soros who is
uh just one of the worst human beings to
have been born in the past two centuries
it's there are a few people who have
done more damage to Human Society than
George Soros over the last 200 years but
it's it's not a long list and he's
pretty high up on that list
is just a reptilian demon scumbag this
guy
and he's uh he lingers on I think he's
in his 90s now
just more evidence that the uh Good Die
Young is the
saying goes all right let's move to this
some moments of cringe in the white
house here's uh we'll just play this for
you Karen Jean pair attempting to break
the ice with a little bit of humor
doesn't go well though
there was a video of him yesterday
FaceTiming with the folks veterans
camping out on Capitol Hill we haven't
seen anything from him today can you
give us a sense of how he's doing
um with having to go back into isolation
frustrated
and how is he dealing with being away
from the first lady well the day's still
young you never know
um but um well the president
making a joke clearly it was not funny
I will try harder next time to be more
funny
um but um look he is continuing to work
from the residence and I just want to
share uh as we all know the president is
fully vaccinated he's fully he's double
boosted he was on treatment for paxlovid
people they're just they're automatons
it was humor I will attempt better humor
in the future
my humorous overchores seem to have not
had the desired effect I will
recalibrate
and then of course we're assured that
he's well he's been he's look he gets
vaccinated five times a day now and uh
and continually gets covered but let's
not draw any conclusions about the
vaccine obviously Kamala Harris is
always ready with the cringe herself
here she is addressing the recent
flooding in
Kentucky and and she says that you know
there are this could have been prevented
flooding and Rain could have been
prevented actually is it by building
like a giant Dome across the sky to stop
the rain from falling on uh on people
well let's find out go ahead
for years our nation and many of us have
discussed have lamented have talked
about the threat of climate change
for years we debated the potential
impact that climate change could have on
our communities on our country and our
world
and today we know the impact if folks
weren't clear about it before just watch
the evening news
and see that the time for debate is long
past
[Applause]
climate change has become a climate
crisis
and a threat
has now become a reality
in recent days deadly floods have swept
through Missouri and Kentucky
washing away entire neighborhoods
leaving at least 35 dead
including babies
children
as has been reported four children from
one family
so the devastation is real
the harm is real
the impact is real
and we are witnessing it in real time
uh yeah the the harm and Devastation is
real that's but that's the only bit of
reality that we heard in those remarks
and I'm I'm really concerned that
on the right when we hear
something like what we just heard there
we don't react to it
with the level of scorn and mockery and
derision that it deserves
in fact this is this is a a common
problem on on the right I think
and some of it's understandable because
you're constantly hearing so much insane
rambling nonsense that you get
desensitized to it after a while but but
um no that when something is completely
absurd and ridiculous
the first and most immediate response
should be mockery and that's what we
should do when we hear a politician
claiming that legislation could have
stopped the rain from falling
okay that's not just her point of view
this is not a this is not a differing
differing perspectives on an issue or
anything like that this is
insane Pagan nonsense
it would be no different if she were to
have broke out into a rain dance right
there on stage
begging the rain gods to stop um dumping
water onto the land it would be it would
be equally as absurd
in fact maybe a little bit less so
just think about what she's saying again
I know people are desensitized to it but
think about it that we could pass a law
that will stop it from raining
what
and not only that by the way but
um
that the law will have this effect in
her mind like pretty pretty quickly
because what she's saying is Well if
only this law had been passed you know
a month ago then maybe this wouldn't
have happened
of course never asked
to explain that
so you've got step one pass a law
step two question mark step three it
stops raining
or we don't want to stop raining
completely but it rains only just the
amount that we need it to and not any
more than than we needed to
and obviously they're never uh required
or put in a position where they have to
Grapple with
the fact that all of these devastating
weather events have been happening on
the planet for billions of years and
they happen before man even walked the
planets
and so that is reason enough why you
can't just point to every devastating
weather event and say that it's the
result of man-caused climate change
because that is to suggest that without
so-called man-made climate change none
of this would be happening but we know
that's not true because it all did
happen before there even was a human
civilization
which means at best some of this
wouldn't be happening if it wasn't for
us driving our SUVs around
like that's that's as far as you can
take the claim
but then how do you know which ones like
which which hurricanes which tornadoes
which tsunamis
which floods
which floods would have happened anyway
as opposed to the ones that would not
have happened if not for you know our
SUVs
I'll have one of course that'd be that's
impossible to determine so instead they
just take this
giant blanket and cover it over
everything
all right this is from NBC Philadelphia
it says following a high-profile case of
alleged racial discrimination against
two black girls
Sea World is being sued for other
alleged instances of pervasive and
appalling discrimination against
children at Sesame Place Philadelphia
so um what the Sea World owned Sesame
Place I guess that's well okay yeah they
do so uh it says the plaintiffs named in
the lawsuit are Baltimore Maryland
residents Quentin Burns and his
five-year-old daughter
who allege that
um former four performers refused to
engage with the girl and other black
children during a meet and greet last
month the performers did readily engage
with numerous white kids according to
the suit
William Murphy one of the lawyers of the
Burns family says racism is horrible
when it's perpetrated against adults but
it's in a separate category altogether
of horror when it's perpetrated against
kids who can't fight back and who have
to struggle to understand how ugly it is
and how it must be eliminated from every
aspect of American Life
the plaintiffs are seeking at least 25
million damages from SeaWorld parks and
entertainment which own Sesame Place on
behalf of all the black people who
visited Sesame Place since July 27 2018.
oh you gotta love this
but you don't have to I mean really you
should hate it but um
so
and this obviously hearkens back to what
we talked about last week or a couple of
weeks ago uh the the five second video
of two young black girls who were at a
parade at Sesame Place and we saw one of
the uh one of the Sesame Street mascots
for one of the characters walked by the
girls
you know because of course it's at a
parade mascots never Matt the normal
thing at a parade is that the mascot
greets personally every single person in
line right that's what that's what
usually happens supposedly and because
they uh the mascot didn't notice these
two girls then that's obviously racism
and that means that there has to be
sensitivity training and lawsuits and
everything else
and now we've got someone jumping onto
that bandwagon and saying oh I was at
Sesame Place too and uh my daughter was
was ignored by some of the mascots and
so now this guy he wants 25 million he
wants 25 million dollars because his
five-year-old daughter didn't get a high
five from a few mascots
and he wants it on behalf of all the
other black people who he just assumes
were racially discriminated against
and so if you're you know black family
that went to Sesame Place at any point
since 2018 good news you will get
Justice for the non-existent racial
discrimination you suffered in the form
of this one guy being made a millionaire
I'm sure that will assuage your your
anguish
it's uh
just out in the open this is a out in
the open scam con artist
and this is what you're able to do if
you uh you know if you have all the
victim points lined up
um
and it's it it's not even something that
needs to be explained I mean if you if
you've
ever been with little kids to any kind
of event theme park parade where there
are mascots you know that it is so
incredibly common for the mascot to just
walk by and not notice and usually what
happened because because they can't the
people in that mascot suit they can't
you know their their their field of
vision is very very small that's why
usually they're carted around by
somebody else you know usually there's
there's a a guide walking with them
pulling them by the hand and um they're
getting swamped by all these little kids
it's 6 000 degrees inside that mascot
suit they're sweat they're they're dying
of dehydration
and heat exhaustion and so they missed
some of the kids
and normally when that happens and your
your child is like a little bit
disappointed oh I wanted to you know I
wanted to say hi to whoever Spider-Man
oh he didn't notice it's okay
and then they get over it
not now though
no now uh rather than telling your kid
to cope with this minor disappointment
rather than helping them to cope with
this minor disappointment because that's
a skill that kids need in life as one of
the most important skills that human
beings need to have in life and if you
want to be a functioning adult
in the world one of the most important
skills is to cope with disappointment
and fortunately
um
as a parent you are given many
opportunities many sort of small scale
low stakes opportunities to teach your
kids that uh that skill
because kids they're very excitable and
they get very into everything that
they're doing and that's what's that's
so what's so wonderful about childhood
and um so if they don't get their way
about something they'll be very dejected
for about 30 seconds it's the worst
thing that's ever happened to them and
then they move on and in that 30 seconds
you have an opportunity as an adult to
teach your kid oh okay well it didn't go
exactly as you wanted you wanted to say
hello to Big Bird and he didn't notice
you and that's okay it's going to be
fine
if you want your kid to be a functioning
adult
but if you want your kid to be a
professional victim
then no you use all of those momentary
disappointments as an opportunity
to validate
your your young child's most
unreasonable perceptions
and then you say oh oh Big Bird didn't
notice you well you're right this is
devastating this is the worst thing
that's ever happened this is the worst
thing that's ever happened to anybody
and they did it because you're black you
know that they did it because they hate
you because for your skin color the Big
Bird hates you he's racist
so that's what gets me about this it's
not you know trying to scam Sesame Place
or Sea World at a 25 million dollars I
don't care about that go ahead you know
whatever
um but
the child abuse the way you're abusing
your child
and trying to turn your child into
exactly the kind of um
self-victimizing
self-obsessed
parasite that you are
you know that's what really gets me
that's what upsets me
all right let's move to this one last
thing
um story from NBC it says celebrity chef
Gordon Ramsay is facing backlash on Tick
Tock from some users after posting a
video in which he appeared to select a
lamb to slaughter for a meal
on Thursday Ramsay posted a video of
himself climbing into a pen of roughly
10 pristine white lamb in the video
Ramsay rubs his hands together while
repeatedly saying yummy
and some people on Tick Tock were
apparently very upset about this first
of all I think we have that video could
we play that
[Music]
um
yum yum yum yum yum yum yum which one's
going in the oven first
you
hmm
oven time
all right so you see that and uh it's I
mean it's
it's a little bit weird I admit I mean
it's a little bit weird to baby talk
your meal
um
slightly strange perhaps I'm also not a
chef I mean he's a chef so this is just
he gets really into his meals and so
that's what he does
but aside from the commentary that he
offers uh I think people should realize
that this is where your food comes from
so the people on Tick Tock who are upset
apparently are just learning where the
meat that they eat comes from
I guess they thought that it just
materializes at the supermarket
just there's a fairy who comes by with a
magic wand and just a little bit of
fairy pixie dust and oh there it is
there's your Lamb Chop
no animals were hurt in the making of
that Lamb Chop
no the the food that you eat comes from
animals who are killed
and that is in fact what sustains
probably your life and it certainly
sustains the lives of uh
billions of people on Earth but here's
the good news
you know because the argument against
eating meat generally is that
at least the so-called sort of ethical
argument against it
is that um
that we're no better than animals like
we're equal to them so we have no right
to consume them
but that argument Cuts us against itself
so to speak because
well if we're no better than animals
this is exactly what animals do they
also eat each other so that's just more
justification for continuing to do what
we're doing I mean either way either
we're equal to animals are no better
than them in which case why should we
hold ourselves to a higher standard
animals eat each other feed off of each
other than we can too or we're Superior
to animals
um we are a a superior species on a
hierarchy and so therefore we have every
moral right to use them in this way
either way
it comes back to
enjoy your hamburger or your Lamb Chop
as the case may be let's get to the
comment section
they're the sweet baby game
lady s says remember that story Matt
told of how he ate the chicken nuggets
his wife wanted to save for their kids
lunch the next day he ate it cold yep
he's president of the husbands eating
the food the wife wanted to save for the
kids club oh absolutely I'm president of
that club I am a I am a long time member
I'm a ranking member of that club to the
point now where my wife doesn't even
bother telling me Oh No we're saving
that food for whatever it's it look
I think it's fair is if the food's in
the kitchen if it's in the refrigerator
then it's fair game from
well it's fair game for me anyway
to eat
um Jesse says on an episode where you
mentioned both gambling and the wildly
desperate uh disparate punishments
issued by the NFL for different offenses
I'd like to point out that Atlanta
Falcons wide receiver Calvin Ridley was
suspended for the entire 22 uh 2022
season for betting 1500 on a game that
didn't evolve his team that's that's a
very good aspect of the story to bring
up
so DeSean Watson is Accused by 26 women
of sexual assault 26
um
massage therapists of sexual assault all
telling strikingly similar stories and
he's going to get six games and
meanwhile there was a wide receiver for
the Atlanta Falcons who bet on some
games his team wasn't involved in the
games and uh and he suspended for the
entire season
yeah it can't exactly make sense of that
and I did get a little bit of pushback
from some people talking about this
yesterday uh I guess thinking that I was
you know
um
becoming a a propagator of of the metoo
movement because I was suggesting
that 26 accusations against DeSean
Watson does count as some kind of
evidence because it does
So when you say well there's no evidence
against him I mean no no there is I mean
26 people accusing you of something is
evidence I'm not saying that it's
um it's decisive I'm not saying that
it's 100 Bulletproof
but it is evidence
and when it comes to the kind of
accusation being made it's the only sort
of evidence that could possibly exist as
I said yesterday if he did sexually
assault any of the 26 women who accuse
him there there couldn't be any physical
evidence of it based on what they're
accusing him of doing
unless they got you know security camera
footage of it but I don't think they
have security cameras inside the room
where they're doing the massages so
if it happened there's not going to be
any physical evidence of it the only
evidence that could exist is accusations
and this is often the case by the way
for these sorts of crimes when they're
alleged this one this is what makes them
so hard to uh adjudicate and this is one
of the reasons why false accusations are
so damaging
but you get to a certain point you know
I think of it very similar to uh you
know it's like Michael Jackson uh people
still they're still people who defend
Michael Jackson even even uh
long sense in the grave they still feel
the need to defend his good name and say
oh no he he never molested any children
yeah but like through years of his life
for decades this guy is Accused by
different children of of uh of child
molestation at a certain point you have
to think like are they all making it up
and if this is the kind of thing that
can happen like why does this happen to
anybody else
most of us can live our lives and we're
not going to have 26 women come out all
at once in accuses of sexual assault and
we're not going to have for decades at a
time different children coming out and
making these kinds of horrible
accusations so
you know either it's that there's this
conspiracy among dozens of people
or this one individual is in fact a
scumbag
right so with the Sean Watson somebody
is lying it's either him or 26 women
they just kind of got to play the
numbers game after a while in mind
all right
um AMV live says when you take the
emotional aspect away from listening to
what Matt is saying in his discussion of
the history of white slavery and the
importance of integrating this
understanding with the current
curriculum you can't help but agree with
his reasoning I learned something new
today that shifted my understanding of
the world I live in for the better and
that alone is exactly why the topic of
history of white slavery should receive
equal attention in regard to the moral
blind spot of all of our ancestors
belief systems as well as the aspects of
those belief systems that we all agree
should not be repeated
um yeah and and you know the discussion
about slavery it it began as we talked
yesterday about the existence of white
slaves because in fact white people were
enslaved also
um
but
this expands beyond that also
you know what we really need to talk
about is the entire
institution of slavery that that
persisted
for thousands of years
and that is actually it's a very um
interesting conversation and an
important one
like it's actually it's a fascinating
question isn't it
how could it be I mean this this thing
that to all of us today is self seems so
self-evidently wrong
nobody needs to explain to us why
slavery is wrong
we don't need that explanation we get it
to us it's self-evident it's intuitive
and yet for thousands of years
almost no one saw that there was
anything wrong with it and not only that
but
um
you know it wasn't like slavery started
as a germ of an idea and then spread to
different civilizations from that one
starting point it is civilizations that
had never come in contact with each
other that were separated by oceans
that were different in so many ways
still had at least this one similarity
of slavery
you know when Europeans
went to um uh went across the ocean to
the to the new world and they
encountered these Indian civilizations
there have been no contact between the
two at all
um
a total you know it's it's in many ways
it's like two aliens from different
planets meeting each other except that
they they both knew what slavery was
how is that how could that have happened
well we can't talk about that because
we're supposed to own there's this one
sliver of the conversation when it comes
to slavery that we're supposed to be
focused on and that's the problem you
know recently we celebrated the one year
anniversary of our podcast morning wire
in this short period of time it's become
one of the top news podcasts I suspect
it's uh because morning wire gives you
all the news you need to know in 15
minutes or less without the manufactured
outrage new episodes are available every
morning seven days a week and they cover
the most important stories of the day so
check out morning wire and apple
podcasts Spotify daily wire Plus or
wherever you listen to podcasts now now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
last week the most overrated musical
artist in history released a new album
uh known John Lennon did not rise from
the grave he is after all only the
second most overrated artist in history
the crown belongs to the queen bee
Beyonce whose mediocre talents cannot on
their own even begin to explain the
worshipful praise her every breath
receives now she's not a bad singer
exactly and she is a relatively talented
dancer but there's nothing about her
music sound or output that's
significantly differentiates her from
any other pop star
yet music critics bow before her and
recite Psalms of Thanksgiving
sometimes they have to contort
themselves into even more tortured
shapes however as has been the case with
her new album Renaissance which just
came out last week she released the
first single break my soul a few weeks
ago and it sounds
well like this
[Music]
[Music]
now on the one hand it's inspiring that
she could compose a hit single on an old
Casio keyboard that she bought at a yard
sale but on the other hand the song is
just not very good I mean it sounds both
retro and perfunctory like a filler song
you might have heard dropped into the
middle of an Ace of Base album in 1995.
now it might make for some decent upbeat
hold music the kind of a thing that
keeps your spirits up while waiting for
the Comcast customer service agent to
come back on the line and tell you that
he can't fix whatever problem you're
having with your service but it's
certainly not the sort of music any
normal person would want to sit and
listen to on purpose
and the whole album is apparently filled
with stuff just like that which you can
tell based on the Hideous pretzel-like
shapes critics are assuming in order to
give the record a positive review I mean
they are desperate to find a way to
positively review this thing the
Atlantic for example calls the song or
rather the whole album
um a mess
says that the songs on the album clatter
wobble and lurch
and derives the whole effort as
indulgent childish exhausting and
ridiculous
and yet uses these adjectives in an
overall positive review
the critic concludes quote but
committing oneself to pleasure as fully
as Beyonce has here takes Defiance and
guts and more deeply faith in the
preciousness of One's Own experience
somehow she has found a way to make
messages of individual empowerment which
can be so trite in pop jolt again
plus he notes the album is very gay and
so that earns at a five-star rating all
on its own but even a big gay album even
one produced by Beyonce
the queen of all creation
is not exempt from the woke mob
Beyonce's team this week had to release
a statement and retroactively change one
of the songs on the album after
receiving intense backlash for the use
of an ableist slur
as many outlets including Yahoo have
reported the song heated off of the
Renaissance album contains the slur spaz
which yeah which Yahoo notes quote is a
derogatory term for [ __ ] diplegia a
form of cerebral palsy which makes it
difficult for people to control some
muscles
because obviously you know when someone
uses the word spaz they're intending to
refer to [ __ ] diplegia
indeed they're intending to insult and
demean everybody with the spat with with
us [ __ ] diplegia
this is obviously the meaning behind the
word and why it must be denounced and
renounced and erased from any book film
or song where it occurs
now if this all sounds like deja vu to
you that's not because you're going
insane it's because the world is going
insane because yes if you recall lizzo
another once Immaculate and sinless
musical genius and poet had to change
one of her songs a couple of months ago
because it also contained the word that
we've just decided now as a slur
now what this shows us is that wokeness
itself
is now the god
Beyonce and her ilk have been basically
demoted
they are now merely priests and
priestesses of of the religion
they're not the gods themselves all must
bow before the woke Altar and make their
offerings
virtue signaling is a requirement from
which none are exempt
now this may seem like a positive
development of sorts as it ensures that
the people who promote this ideology
will be forced to take their own
medicine but it's less positive when you
realize that wokeness is mass hysteria
now it is just an avalanche of stupidity
and Insanity that nobody controls
that to me was the most Salient and
important point in the latest
controversy where people are once again
spazzing out over the stupidest
imaginable thing but then
I went and listened to the portion of
the song that contains this allegedly
offensive lyric
my eardrums have yet to recover from the
experience and now yours will suffer the
same fate I'm afraid here it is listen
your face
Chanel
now
when I hear lyrics like yummy yummy yum
make that bummy heated make a pretty
girl talk that
whiskey till I'm tipsy glitter on my
kitty cool it down down down my pretty
bad bad make the bad bad glitchy fine
fine fine fine fine
Liberated Living like we ain't got time
yada yada yada yada yada yada yada
spazzing on that ass spaz on that Ass
Fan me quick girl I need my glass when I
hear those lyrics
I am not especially offended by the word
spaz I can barely hear the word by the
time we've made it to that part because
I've been reduced to a nearly catatonic
state
the idiocy in the song is so potent so
pure so uncut that I have overdosed on
it this is medical grade stupidity you
can actually feel your head start to
throb and burn as your brain cells
self-immolate in protest
listen to us on repeat for 30 minutes
would have the same neurological effect
as a lobotomy that's a scientific fact
but even on just one brief listen the
song is dumb enough to provoke a
full-fledged existential crisis causing
the listener to question the very
purpose and meaning of human existence
it's the worst thing I've ever heard and
yet it's also indistinguishable from 95
of pop music it all bleeds together into
one putrid toxic malignant cancerous
lump
now it seems trite I understand to
complain
about dumb pop music
but that's only because we take for
granted that most popular music will be
aggressively ear bleedingly bad
but we really shouldn't take this for
granted it's a very modern predicament
that most of our artists produce vulgar
inane disgusting rubbish that is
essentially the auditory equivalent of
drinking stagnant water out of a trash
can lid it was not always this way it
wasn't artists through history have had
varying degrees of talent and Genius of
course but they've all been artists at
least they have strived historically to
produce things that are beautiful and
true
an important
artists have not historically been a
class of wealthy semi-literate
self-aggrandizing donkeys this is a
situation peculiar to the Modern Age
and like most things that are peculiar
to our age we assume that it's always
been this way and will always remain
this way and so we don't react to it the
way we should and how should we react
well probably the most reasonable
response to a song like that is to vomit
all over yourself
but a slightly cleaner and more subtle
reaction would be to recoil and disgust
and to be offended not in a petty
oversensitive kind of way but in the
deeper and and more righteous sense of
the term offended by the vulgar
stupidity and shamelessness of these pop
industry parasites who wish to make our
children Dumber while feeding on their
souls and their minds like some kind of
brain eating amoeba
most of all we should dispense with the
notion
that art and Beauty are entirely
subjective they're not right as if the
Sistine Chapel and a smiley face smeared
in feces on the wall of a padded cell
have equal artistic legitimacy as if a
sane person could be justified in
preferring either one
no far from subjective Beauty and art
are transcendent
I mean beauty is truth it's eternal
to understand this fact is to take one
of the most important red pills you can
take
but you can't do that
until you ditch all of this pop music
garbage
starting with Beyonce who is awful and
stupid
and talentless and terrible
and most essential especially today she
is canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day Godspeed
[Music]
the Matt wall show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover production manager Pavel vadoski
our associate producer is McKenna Waters
shows edited by Jeff Tomlin Our audio is
mixed by Mike cormina hair makeup is
done by Cherokee heart the mat wall show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2022. the White House tries
to spin record high gas prices into an
accomplishment Joe Biden abandons Taiwan
to communist China and a January 6th
there gets sentenced to seven years in
prison after his kid turns him in
go check it out on the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]